All right, I know we want to get started here on the show, but I just got an email from my mom Yeah, what does it say classic? It's just a list of words as alternatives for swear words because she thinks I swear too much She gave you a whole list of swear words. Yeah, she's giving me like one like like 11 alternatives. Yeah Anyway This is fucking smart list. Let's go Hi talking hi talking talking loving learning ways are we let's just change the title of this thing to talkers You think that's a good. I don't think it's too late talkers and and we could send a little horse
好吧，我知道我们想在节目里开始了，但我刚收到我妈发来的一封邮件。是啊，她说什么了，经典吗？那只是一份脏话替代词列表，因为她觉得我脏话讲得太多了。她给了你整整一份脏话列表。是啊，她给了我大概11个替代词。好吧，不管怎样，这真是个他妈的聪明的列表。我们开始吧。嗨，谈话，嗨，谈话，谈话，热爱学习方式，我们是吗？我们把这个节目的标题改成“谈话者”吧。你觉得这主意好吗？我觉得还不算太晚，“谈话者”，而且我们可以送出一匹小马。
Well, it's just that is Just that is a it's a think bar looking for freebies and this is Again think bar. That's t-h-i-n-k sure with an exclamation point that it wasn't helping with your thing Yeah, I was gonna say and and that goes down great with smart water You exactly that's great. This is why you're on the talkers podcast I'm so happy that you do most of your thinking you don't do most you're thinking out loud I'm sitting here uncomfortably. I've got I've got one of very sweetly the other day
嗯，这只是，这只是一个，这是一个寻找免费赠品的“思考吧”，而且这又是“思考吧”。那是T-H-I-N-K，当然，后面加个感叹号，它对你的事情没什么帮助。是啊，我正想说，而且这和“聪明水”搭配起来很棒。你说的对，这就是为什么你会在“谈话者”播客上。我很高兴你大部分时间都在思考，你不是在自言自语。我坐在这里很不舒服。我前几天非常贴心地得到了一个。
I hurt I tweaked my back and so I've been I've been kind of laid up and All of a sudden Jason appeared at my house true story and he brought me over three of the those icy hot patches for me Ah, I know I didn't even ask him. He just showed up and that was this two days ago. Was that weird? I mean it was it's you know, I do something super super nice Twice a year. Maybe maybe no probably once a year It was unsolicited and he showed up and I was sitting there and he just showed up and he gave it to me It was really nice. Really. I've got one on right now. I think I may have revealed how much I love you there It was very sweet. I'm now. I'm shy. I know maybe you can come over and bathe me then, you know
我受伤了，我扭伤了背，所以我一直处于休养状态。突然间，杰森出现在我家，这是真实故事，他给我带来了三个那种冰热贴。啊，我知道，我甚至没问他。他只是出现了，那是两天前的事。那很奇怪吗？我的意思是，你知道，我一年做一次超级超级好的事。也许，不，可能一年一次。那是主动的，他出现了，我坐在那儿，他只是出现了，然后把它给了我。这真的很棒。真的。我现在就贴着一个。我想我可能已经在那儿流露出了我有多爱你。这非常贴心。我现在，我很害羞。我知道，也许你可以过来帮我洗澡，你知道的。
I just want to say so we've got a guest on here today a guy Does somebody have a washing machine going? Yeah, they're they're very busy and By the way, it's right on brand for our guest because he's a very busy guy and has been for a long time He's a man who wears many many different hats He's a in my eyes in my view a comedic God he was on SNL He worked on Conan as a writer. He created some some really iconic sketches at SNL He then moved to then he came back out here to California
我只是想说，我们今天有一位嘉宾，一个家伙。有人在用洗衣机吗？是的，他们非常忙。顺便说一句，这非常符合我们嘉宾的形象，因为他是一个非常忙碌的人，而且已经忙了很长时间了。他是一个身兼数职的人。在我眼里，在我看来，他是一位喜剧之神。他曾在《周六夜现场》工作。他曾在柯南的节目里担任编剧。他在《周六夜现场》创作了一些非常标志性的短剧。然后他搬到了，然后他回到了加利福尼亚。
We originally from Illinois near near where Sean's from. Oh, wow And and they work on SNL worked on SNL and wrote on the Ben Stiller show Then created a show with our friend David called Mr. Show with Bob and Dave. Oh, yes, of course, ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Bob Otterkirk. Hello. I love you brought us right up to it We got it. Come on. You got that. You got that from me moving around my kitchen You should have heard the names in my head. I was shuffling through Sudeikis was there for a second and then and then no, I don't think it's there's a Chicago there and look at you, Bob Otterkirk. Yeah, there is. I think Sudeikis, what part of Chicago? He did a little bit of Chicago. He did. Yeah. Well, he was in second city Pretty sure he's a Chicago guy. He's from Kansas. What part of Chicago?
我们最初来自伊利诺伊州，就在肖恩家附近。哦，哇。而且他们曾在《周六夜现场》工作，并在《本·斯蒂勒秀》担任编剧。然后和我们的朋友大卫一起创作了一个节目，叫《鲍勃与大卫的短剧秀》。哦，是的，当然，女士们先生们，鲍勃·奥登科克先生。你好。我爱你，你直接把我们带到了正题。我们做到了。来吧。你做到了。你从我厨房里走来走去时就做到了。你应该听听我脑子里的名字。我一直在翻找，苏戴奇斯在那儿待了一会儿，然后，不，我不认为那里有个芝加哥，看看你，鲍勃·奥登科克。是的，确实有。我想苏戴奇斯，芝加哥哪部分？他确实在芝加哥待过一点。他待过。是的。好吧，他在“第二城”剧团。我很确定他是芝加哥人。他是堪萨斯人。芝加哥哪部分？
Well, I went to college my first year where you're from, Sean. Which college? I went to COD You did? College of different years. I lived two blocks from that. That's our cue, Will. Let's take a tight five, you and me, Will Well, I was 16 when I went to college. No way. That's not surprising. So I I was kind of afraid of going away to college. I felt like I was so young I would I would really not. Well, did we grow up near each other than if you went to college of DuPage? Yeah, I went to Naperville. I grew up in Naperville. That's insane. I grew up in Glen Owens. You know what? That's so funny because when Jason was 16, he dropped out of eighth grade. So that's like this very simple story. Now, so 16, you went to college at 16. That means you're one of those
好吧，我大学第一年去了你家乡的学校，肖恩。哪所大学？我去了杜佩奇学院。你去了？不同年份的学院。我住在离那儿两个街区的地方。那是我们的提示，威尔。我们来个五分钟的简短交流，你和我，威尔。好吧，我上大学时才16岁。不会吧。这并不令人惊讶。所以我有点害怕去外地读大学。我觉得我太年轻了，我真的不会。好吧，如果我们都去了杜佩奇学院，那我们是不是在附近长大的？是的，我去了内珀维尔。我在内珀维尔长大。这太疯狂了。我在格伦埃林长大。你知道吗？这太搞笑了，因为杰森16岁时，他从八年级辍学了。所以这是一个非常简单的故事。现在，16岁，你16岁就上大学了。这意味着你是那种
not-dumb guys. No, no. You and Keith Overman. It doesn't mean anything. It doesn't mean a damn thing except that I found out I could leave high school and they'd let me go and I was like, all right. So then in 10th grade, they said you're done. I just went to school young when I was a little kid and then I left a year early. So I cut two years off. But was that normal in your family? You have like six siblings, right? Right. Seven kids. So six, yes, siblings. And any drunks? Any drunks, my dad. My dad covered the whole, he did it for all of us. He said, but the last thing he said before he died was I drank all the booze.
不笨的家伙。不，不。你和基思·奥弗曼。这什么也代表不了。这什么该死的意思都没有，除了我发现我可以离开高中，他们会让我走，我就想，好吧。所以到了十年级，他们说你完成了。我小时候上学很早，然后我提前一年离开了。所以我缩短了两年。但在你家里这正常吗？你有六个兄弟姐妹，对吧？对。七个孩子。所以六个，是的，兄弟姐妹。有酒鬼吗？有酒鬼，我爸爸。我爸爸包揽了所有，他为我们所有人做了。他说，但他死前说的最后一件事是：我喝光了所有的酒。
I'm so sorry, kids. I drank it all. Now there's none left for you. So wait. So in 11th grade, they said you need not go to 12th grade? All my friends were a year older than me in high school. All my close friends. And they were all leaving. And I thought, well, I don't want to be here if they're leaving. So I asked, I went to the office. I said, can I leave? And they looked at my number of credits and they said, yeah, you can. And after Jason, just, you know, since then I've heard that my high school has raised the, they turned up the credit number so that that's not going to happen so easily. And all these ninth graders. Sounds like quite a process.
我很抱歉，孩子们。我把它全喝光了。现在没剩给你们了。等等。所以十一年级时，他们说你不需要上十二年级了？我所有的高中好友都比我大一岁。我所有亲密的朋友。他们都要离开了。我想，好吧，如果他们要走，我不想留在这儿。所以我问，我去了办公室。我说，我可以走吗？他们看了看我的学分，他们说，是的，你可以。在杰森之后，你知道，从那以后我听说我的高中提高了，他们提高了学分要求，所以这种情况不会那么容易发生了。还有所有这些九年级的学生。听起来是个相当复杂的过程。
Did you have to go to junior college for a couple of years to get into the kind of university you wanted? No, I went to COD, which is a small community college where Sean grew up, which is only a 20 minute drive from where I lived because I could have gone to any college. No, I mean, I got my, I got my degree from high school. And, and I just, I just didn't feel like I'd fit in at all. And then in college, what did you leave with? What did you major in? I went to three different colleges and four different four colleges. The fourth one was just a class I took. Anyway, look, no, I want to know what you graduated with. I sound like a hero and a genius, a real Einstein. He's trying to hide how a highbrow the major was. Is it archaeological
你必须去社区大学读几年才能进入你想去的大学吗？不，我去了杜佩奇学院，那是肖恩长大的地方的一所小型社区大学，离我住的地方只有20分钟车程，因为我本可以去任何大学的。不，我的意思是，我拿到了高中的学位。而且，我只是，我只是觉得我一点也不适合那里。然后在大学里，你拿到了什么学位？你主修什么？我去了三所不同的大学，四所大学。第四所只是我上的一门课。不管怎样，听着，不，我想知道你毕业时拿到了什么学位。我听起来像个英雄和天才，一个真正的爱因斯坦。他试图掩盖这个专业有多么高深。是考古学
theories? No, no, no, no. I got a major in broadcasting. And a minor in philosophy. Because you wanted to be an on air guy. I wanted to be an intellectual on air chatting guy. And here we are on the dumbest podcast ever made. Honestly, Jason, yes. Smash cut to smart. I'm going to lower the bar on this podcast, which is quite something. Good luck. Well, you've been, you've been successfully hiding your, your, your, your sophisticated intellectual high brownness for years. Not to imply that you've been coming across as a dumbass, but you certainly seem very approachable anytime I've ever talked to you. Wait, so Bob, so Bob, let me take us back for a second. So you go to college, you go to four colleges because you had to show everybody up. And then when was the moment,
理论吗？不，不，不，不。我主修广播。辅修哲学。因为你想成为一名广播员。我想成为一名在广播里侃侃而谈的知识分子。而现在我们却在这个有史以来最愚蠢的播客上。老实说，杰森，是的。直接切入聪明。我要降低这个播客的门槛，这可真了不起。祝你好运。好吧，你一直，你一直成功地隐藏了你的，你的，你的，你的复杂知识分子的高深。并不是说你表现得像个笨蛋，但每当我跟你交谈时，你看起来确实非常平易近人。等等，所以鲍勃，所以鲍勃，让我带我们回到一秒钟前。所以你去上大学，你去了四所大学，因为你想向所有人炫耀。然后是什么时候，
so when did you start getting into, when did you start getting into comedy, performing and comedy writing and working with Smigel and Conan and all that? What was that? Honestly, I started writing comedy like diligently, like as part of my daily routine when I was like 10. Wow. I just loved, I just love sketch comedy. Like knock, knock jokes. What's a 10 year old writing? No, no, no, sketch fake commercials, parody commercials. That would be the first thing. Were you a big Saturday Night Live fan at that age? I always liked Saturday Night Live. I was a big Monty Python fan. Yeah, same. Right. And I particularly liked the Saturday Night Live episodes that Steve Martin hosted in the early years. Those were another cut above everything else on the show, which was a great
所以你什么时候开始进入，你什么时候开始进入喜剧，表演和喜剧写作，并与斯迈格尔和柯南他们一起工作？那是什么时候？老实说，我从10岁左右就开始勤奋地写喜剧了，就像我日常生活的一部分一样。哇。我只是喜欢，我只是喜欢短剧喜剧。比如敲门笑话。一个10岁的孩子在写什么？不，不，不，短剧，虚假广告，模仿广告。那会是第一件事。你在那个年纪是《周六夜现场》的忠实粉丝吗？我一直喜欢《周六夜现场》。我是蒙提·派森的忠实粉丝。是的，我也是。对。我特别喜欢史蒂夫·马丁在早期主持的《周六夜现场》剧集。那些比节目里的其他任何东西都高出一个档次，那是一个伟大的
show. And it's first five years, a great, great show. But Steve Martin hosting was like super charged. But I loved Monty Python. In fact, when I interviewed with Lorne, I, Lorne Michaels from Saturday Night Live. Yeah. When I, when I did get an interview with Lorne to be a writer at SNL, I don't know. I was sitting out there, you know, he makes you sit, he makes you wait for hours. Like, like one AM appointment, right? You know, like Jeanine Garofalo famously waited six hours to go in for her meeting. Mine was not that bad. It was like an hour. I'm still waiting. But nothing gets me more nervous than waiting for a meeting. Anyway, sorry, go ahead. And he asked you, he asked me, what do I, what, what do I like? What shows do
节目。而且是前五年，一个非常非常棒的节目。但史蒂夫·马丁主持时就像超级充电一样。但我喜欢蒙提·派森。事实上，当我面试洛恩时，我是说《周六夜现场》的洛恩·迈克尔斯。是的。当我确实得到面试机会去《周六夜现场》当编剧时，我不知道。我坐在外面，你知道，他让你坐着，他让你等上几个小时。就像凌晨一点的预约，对吧？你知道，比如珍妮·加罗法洛就很有名地等了六个小时才进去开会。我的没那么糟。大概一个小时。我还在等。但没有什么比等待会议更让我紧张的了。不管怎样，抱歉，请继续。他问你，他问我，我喜欢什么？我喜欢什么节目
I like? And I'm like, Monty Python, he's like, have you, you know, do you like what we're doing here? And I'm like, not so much. I thought he wouldn't want to get his ass kissed. I really thought not only do I genuinely like Monty Python more than this show, I thought he doesn't want to hear me go, oh, I wish I could work here. You're so great. This is the best thing ever. And that's all he wants to hear, right? That's all he wants to hear. So I go in and I'm a real standoffish, which I could be, right? Yep. I'm good at it. Yes. Yeah. And I'm, but I really kind of sort of purposefully was like, I'm not going to kiss this guy's ass. He doesn't want to hear that. He wants to hear that I have some perspective on what they're doing here and comedy. And,
我喜欢？我说蒙提·派森，他说，你（你知道），你喜欢我们在这里做的事情吗？我说，没那么喜欢。我以为他不会想让人拍马屁。我真的认为，我不但比这个节目更喜欢蒙提·派森，我还认为他不想听我说，哦，我真希望我能在这里工作。你太棒了。这是有史以来最好的事情。而那正是他想听到的，对吧？那正是他想听到的。所以我进去了，我表现得很冷淡，我可以做到，对吧？是的。我很擅长。是的。而且我，但我确实有点故意表现得像，我不会拍这个家伙的马屁。他不想听那个。他想听听我对他们在这里所做的事情和喜剧有一些看法。而且，
and I also knew Lauren liked Monty Python a lot too. So I was like, look, Monty Python was the best and still to me is the best, not this show. And you do your little show. Meanwhile, I'm a waiter at Ed DeBevix. I'm a fucking waiter. And I'm sitting with Lauren Michaels going, nah, it's not so good. It's not so good what you do here. But you got hired. How did you get that interview, Bob? Like where did that come from? Smigel. Robert Smigel was a really important writer at Saturday Night Live almost from the time he got hired. He was just built to write for that show. And he just wrote so many great sketches. There's that great star Trek trekky sketch with Shatner where he says, get a life to these people. It's such a great moment, but so many,
而且我也知道洛恩也很喜欢蒙提·派森。所以我当时想，看，蒙提·派森是最好的，对我来说现在仍然是最好的，而不是这个节目。而你做你的小节目。与此同时，我在埃德·德贝维克斯餐厅当服务员。我他妈是个服务员。我坐在洛恩·迈克尔斯对面说，不，没那么好。你在这里做的事情没那么好。但你还是被录用了。你是怎么得到那个面试机会的，鲍勃？那是怎么来的？斯迈格尔。罗伯特·斯迈格尔从被录用开始几乎就是《周六夜现场》里一位非常重要的编剧。他天生就是为那个节目写剧本的。他写了太多伟大的短剧。有那个伟大的《星际迷航》短剧，沙特纳对这些人说“找点正事做”。那是一个非常伟大的时刻，但还有很多，
so many. I mean, the thing is, Robert's known for triumph, the insult comic dog and the number of wonderful, amazing sketches that just made that show relevant and important and worthwhile that he wrote is hard to express. And it's not just the recurring ones. I mean, he wrote Mr. Short-Term Memory and all these and the Bears Guys and all that stuff. But he wrote just the greatest thing. So he was really important there. And Lauren knew that. And Robert and I had been roommates and he had seen me in a show in Chicago and liked it and thought I was really a good performer and funny writer. And so we had begun writing a sketch show when he got hired at Saturday Night Live. So he sort of was a pipeline for me. I was writing my material and he would share it with
很多。我的意思是，问题是，罗伯特以“凯旋，侮辱漫画狗”而闻名，他写的那些让节目变得相关、重要且值得一看的精彩绝伦的短剧，很难用语言表达。而且不仅仅是那些反复出现的。我的意思是，他写了“短期记忆先生”和所有这些，还有“熊人”等等。但他写的东西简直是最棒的。所以他在那里非常重要。洛恩也知道这一点。罗伯特和我曾是室友，他在芝加哥看过我的演出，很喜欢，认为我是一个非常好的表演者和有趣的编剧。所以当他在《周六夜现场》被录用时，我们已经开始写一个短剧节目了。所以他算是我的渠道。我在写我的素材，他会和
other writers in the office. And I would also work with him on the phone and punch up his sketches for the week. I actually got a sketch on when I wasn't writing there before I got hired there called Side Show of the Stars. You remember Circus of the Stars? Yeah, absolutely. Jason, were you ever asked to do that? I proudly turned it down one year. I think I was upset with the skill I was offered. I wanted trapeze and I think I got dog tamer. It's so great, Bob. You're one of like a number of guests who have come on and mentioned these like great celebrity shows that were on in the 80s and they always go, Jason, were you on that? There's always a good chance that he was. I know you guys had Paul McCartney on because I listened to that because he's so great. That was
办公室里的其他编剧分享。我也会在电话里和他一起工作，为他每周的短剧润色。事实上，在我被录用之前，我有一个短剧被采用了，叫《明星杂耍秀》。你记得《明星马戏团》吗？是的，绝对记得。杰森，有人邀请你参加过吗？我自豪地拒绝了一年。我想我对提供的技能感到不满。我想要空中飞人，我想我得到的是驯狗。这太棒了，鲍勃。你是为数不多提到这些80年代伟大名人节目的嘉宾之一，他们总是问，杰森，你参加过那个吗？他参加过的几率总是很高。我知道你们请过保罗·麦卡特尼，因为我听过那一期，因为他太棒了。那真是
such a great episode. Anyone who's listening to this episode and hasn't listened to that, stop right now. Thank you for the plug. Thank you for the plug of our old episodes. I appreciate it. Such a great episode. Jason, were you invited to be on the Wings ABC special? No, the what? Gotta watch. This is the worst thing McCartney ever did and I'm a huge fan. God bless. I immediately went to the TV show wins. No, his band Wings. They thought, I forget the logic of this. I was reading about, I was reading about McCartney and I thought, I read about this thing where he did a one hour special for ABC for network prime time and it was so bad. Back in the 80s? I love watching that season. Yeah, with Wings. Oh boy. It would probably do great today. Bob Odenkirk, you're
非常棒的一集。任何正在听这一集且还没听过那一集的人，现在就停下来。谢谢你的宣传。谢谢你宣传我们的旧节目。我很感激。真是太棒的一集了。杰森，你被邀请参加《Wings》ABC特别节目了吗？不，什么？得看。这是麦卡特尼做过的最糟糕的事情，而我是他的超级粉丝。上帝保佑。我立刻想到了电视节目《Wings》。不，他的乐队Wings。他们认为，我忘了这个逻辑了。我当时在读关于麦卡特尼的事，我想，我读到他为ABC网络黄金时段做了一个一小时的特别节目，那真是太糟糕了。80年代？我喜欢看那一季。是的，和Wings一起。哦，天哪。如果放在今天可能会很火。鲍勃·奥登科克，你
in one of the biggest shows in the history of television, Breaking Bad. Yeah, I'm a small part. And Better Call Saul. Let's make that connection to how you get to Breaking Bad because I love this. Bob, your trajectory is one of my favorite of all time and I'm very fond of you and you and I have a long history. Bob and I made two movies together. I'm a big fan of you, Will Arnett. I think you're one of the great actors. One of the greats. Still hasn't had a chance to show everything you can do on screen. And I apologize for not helping you do that. No, Bob. You did great with those movies. Those two movies, listener, as soon as you're done running through the Paul McCartney episode, you need to watch both Let's Go to Prison and
在电视史上最伟大的节目之一《绝命毒师》里。是的，我只是个小角色。还有《风骚律师》。让我们建立起你是如何进入《绝命毒师》的联系，因为我喜欢这个。鲍勃，你的轨迹是我最喜欢的轨迹之一，我非常喜欢你，你和我有着悠久的历史。鲍勃和我一起拍过两部电影。我是你的忠实粉丝，威尔·阿内特。我认为你是伟大的演员之一。最伟大的人之一。还没有机会展示你在银幕上能做的一切。我很抱歉没能帮你做到这一点。不，鲍勃。你拍那些电影拍得很好。那两部电影，听众们，一旦你们听完保罗·麦卡特尼那一集，你们就需要看《去监狱吧》和
Brother Solomon. You did a great job directing those movies, despite Will Arnett being in those. So my experience with Bob was, I didn't know him. Bob came on Arrest Development the first season, one of the first episodes, Jason, you remember and did those awesome scenes with David where you played the marriage counselor and then Bob and David ended up taking over each other's roles and it was fucking insane. And I was so, you know, I was such a huge Mr. I knew David a little bit, but I was such a huge Mr. Show fan. It really, to me, was just the pinnacle of sketch comedy. And I loved it so much. Anybody in comedy, that's like, yeah, that is the show. It's just it for me. And you came, I remember one time we went to, before we did
《所罗门兄弟》。你导演那些电影做得很好，尽管威尔·阿内特在里面。所以我对鲍勃的经历是，我不认识他。鲍勃在《发展受阻》第一季，第一集，杰森，你记得，和戴维演了那些很棒的场景，你扮演婚姻咨询师，然后鲍勃和戴维最终互换了角色，那真是太疯狂了。我当时，你知道，我是《短剧秀》的超级粉丝。对我来说，那简直是短剧喜剧的巅峰。我太喜欢它了。任何从事喜剧的人，都会说，是的，那就是那个节目。对我来说就是这样。你来了，我记得有一次我们去了，在我们做
Let's Go to Prison and we went to a, I forget, we were at somebody's house like a Christmas party or something. And you ended up talking to me and I was like, man, I can't believe I'm talking to Bob. I'm Bob Odenkirk. I just, I just, and then you were like, here's, here's where I think that you could, and you like gave me some advice like on, and I really listened to every word and it was great. You'd had a couple. You'd had a couple because your dad had left a couple beers out before he came. They were warm. It was like a treasure hunt. But it was so awesome. And then, and then not long after that they, let's go to prison came together and I got to go and work with you. And really you, me and Dax spent so much time in that, first of all, in that prison
《去监狱吧》之前，我们去了某人的家里，参加圣诞派对之类的。你最终和我说话，我当时想，天哪，我不敢相信我在和鲍勃说话。我是鲍勃·奥登科克。我只是，我只是，然后你说，这是，这是我认为你可以，你给了我一些建议，关于，我真的听了每一个字，那太棒了。你喝了几杯。你喝了几杯，因为你爸爸在他来之前留了几瓶啤酒。它们是温的。就像寻宝一样。但这太棒了。然后，然后没过多久，《去监狱吧》就成型了，我有机会去和你一起工作。真的，你，我和达克斯在那个，首先，在那个监狱里花了很多时间
in Joliet, Illinois, which is a prison. My dad drove us by that prison when I was a kid. He drove me in here. No, he said, he said, look over there, boys. We drove right by that two lane highway that runs beside the prison. He goes, that's Joliet Correctional Facility. If you do bad things, you're going to end up in there. It is a scary prison. Very frightening. It's fucking scary as shit. In fact, Melissa McCarthy was on, she grew up nearby there too. And she said that when she drove by with her mom in her Catholic school dress, her mom would say like, don't let them see you. Right. So scary. So we go when we make that movie and you had just had, you've done Mr. Show to great acclaim. You also were on Larry Sanders, one of the other great influential comedies of
在伊利诺伊州乔利埃特，那是一个监狱。我小时候我爸爸开车带我们经过那个监狱。他开车带我进去。不，他说，他说，看那边，孩子们。我们开车经过了监狱旁边那条双车道公路。他说，那是乔利埃特惩教所。如果你做坏事，你最终会进到那里。那是一个可怕的监狱。非常吓人。真是他妈的吓人。事实上，梅丽莎·麦卡锡也上过节目，她也在附近长大。她说当她穿着天主教学校的制服和她妈妈开车经过时，她妈妈会说，别让他们看见你。对。太可怕了。所以我们去拍那部电影，你刚刚，你拍了《短剧秀》，获得了巨大的赞誉。你还参加了《拉里·桑德斯秀》，另一部伟大的、有影响力的喜剧
all time to great acclaim. Then you start directing and then, well, listen, let's go to prison. I did my best. Both those movies are so damn good. Yeah. They're so funny. We never know why shit. And Bob and I, we had it. Yeah, that's really true. I think it's true, Will. I mean, you don't know how these things are going to come out. I mean, there's so many components and that goes for everything, but certainly a feature film. And you just got hope that it all marries up and somehow is as good as what you hoped it would be or maybe better. I thought about this a lot with Brother Solomon. I felt a certain amount of guilt because I love Will so much as well. Will Forte. Will Forte. And he wrote that for us to do. And we went and did this
有史以来获得了巨大的赞誉。然后你开始导演，然后，好吧，听着，《去监狱吧》。我尽力了。那两部电影都太他妈好了。是的。它们太搞笑了。我们永远不知道为什么。鲍勃和我，我们做到了。是的，那确实是真的，威尔。我的意思是，你不知道这些事情会变成什么样。我的意思是，有很多组成部分，这适用于一切，但肯定适用于故事片。你只能希望这一切结合在一起，以某种方式和你希望的一样好，或者更好。我经常思考《所罗门兄弟》。我感到一种负罪感，因为我也非常喜欢威尔。威尔·福特。他为我们写了那个剧本。我们去拍了这部
movie. And I always, as you know, it was one of the funniest scripts I've ever read to date. Yeah. Yeah. And it just incredible. And I always felt like, fuck, man, I wish it was better for Will because I loved him so much. Well, I actually had this horrible brain fart that comes to you after you fail miserably, maybe sometimes days later or in this case, like a year later. And I thought, I wonder how that script would be if you shot it as a low budget movie on location, not building the sets, because it's already such a heightened, there's such heightened characters. And that was what I think really threw me off. I first got that script. I read it. They asked me if I wanted to direct it. And I thought it's too much of a
电影。我一直，如你所知，那是我读过的最有趣的剧本之一。是的。是的。而且简直不可思议。我一直觉得，该死，伙计，我希望它对威尔来说更好，因为我太喜欢他了。好吧，我实际上有这种可怕的脑子短路，在你惨败后会出现，有时几天后，或者在这种情况下，像一年后。我想，如果你把它拍成一部低成本的实景电影，而不是搭建布景，那剧本会怎么样，因为它已经是一个高度，有高度夸张的角色。那是我认为真正让我困扰的地方。我第一次拿到那个剧本。我读了它。他们问我是否想导演它。我想这太像一部
meta movie. It's too, everything's too conceptualized in these people and how they look at life. It's almost like a cartoon or like, anyway, I said, I just don't know how to make this work. And I handed it back. And then I got a call like a week later, Will Arnett wants to be in it. And come on, Fortale be in it. And we'll all get together. It'll be so much fun. And it's such a fun script. Come on. And directing is fun. It's really fun. And I'm like, ah, shit. Yeah, okay, I'll do it. But I just didn't, I hadn't figured out, look, when you, it's weird to say this, because we just acknowledged that movies are such a uncertain enterprise. So you can never really know for sure. But I would say that in that case, I didn't have that core principle
元电影了。太，一切都太概念化了，这些人以及他们看待生活的方式。它几乎像一部卡通片，或者像，不管怎样，我说，我只是不知道怎么让它奏效。我把它还回去了。然后我一周后接到电话，威尔·阿内特想参演。来吧，福特也会参演。我们都会聚在一起。那会很有趣。而且这是一个非常有趣的剧本。来吧。导演很有趣。真的很有趣。我当时想，啊，该死。是的，好吧，我会做的。但我只是没，我还没弄清楚，看，当你，说这话很奇怪，因为我们刚刚承认电影是一个如此不确定的事业。所以你永远无法真正确定。但我会说，在这种情况下，我没有那个核心原则
to build around. And so I was going off what I read. And when you read it, it can read kind of like a version of Dumb and Dumber, which is to say they went with, you know, these bold, broad characters. And it would have been neat to take that same sensibility and those characters, but land it in a really low budget, like low-fi world. It might have worked. I think it might have worked great. And you could have done it. And Fortale could have done it. Same cast. Yeah, I think that you're probably right. And I think that you, you and Will and I should get together and remake. It would be the fucking hilarious thing to do. Funniest thing to do. The way we want to. But I will say this, a real testament to Bob was years later,
可以围绕它构建。所以我根据我读到的东西来做。当你读它时，它读起来有点像《阿呆与阿瓜》的版本，也就是说他们选择了，你知道，这些大胆、宽泛的角色。如果能采取同样的敏感度和那些角色，但把它降落在一个非常低成本、低保真的世界里，那会很整洁。它可能奏效。我认为它可能奏效得很好。你可以做到。福特也可以做到。同样的演员阵容。是的，我想你可能是对的。而且我认为你，你和威尔和我应该聚在一起重拍。那会是极其搞笑的事情。最有趣的事情。按照我们想要的方式。但我会说这一点，对鲍勃的一个真正证明是多年后，
I think we all felt a little shitty about it because it didn't turn out the way we wanted to. And I ran into Bob and Bob went out of his way to come over and say, Hey, man, I'm really sorry. You said that I felt like I let you down. And I kind of said the same thing. And we kind of, not that we needed to make, make up, but we did. And I thought it really, I don't know, man, you don't get a lot of that in, in, in, in this thing that we all do. And you were, well, I'm always surprised when I go into people's offices and they have movies, movie posters for things that were just terrible. And you're like, you don't be proud of that. Well, because it's so hard to get stuff made. People are so excited to actually get something
我想我们都觉得有点糟糕，因为它没有变成我们想要的样子。我遇到了鲍勃，鲍勃特意走过来，说，嘿，伙计，我真的很抱歉。你说我感觉我让你失望了。我也说了同样的话。我们有点，不是说我们需要和解，但我们确实和解了。我觉得它真的，我不知道，伙计，你在我们所有人做的这件事里得不到很多那种东西。而且你是，好吧，每当我走进人们的办公室，看到那些糟糕透顶的电影海报时，我总是很惊讶。你会想，你不会为那个感到骄傲吧。好吧，因为制作东西太难了。人们对真正制作出东西感到非常兴奋
made. But I just, I always, I wanted to say to you that I've always really appreciated that when you did that, it really meant a lot to me. I think that you're really fucking cool and big and cool person. So just that's that. And we can move on. Wait, I gotta, I gotta, I gotta tell my Sean. Hey, story. Here we go. This is a great one. Now, Sean, have I ever told you this one? I don't know. Have I ever told you that I was invited to do a part on Will and Grace? Okay. You don't remember this because it only lasted one morning. Did you do a table read? I did not do the table read. Okay. Okay. So tell me if I got this right. So I had little kids at home. Were they yours? And I was, I was writing a movie with David Cross
。但我只是，我一直，我想对你说，我一直非常感激你这样做，这对我意义重大。我认为你真的很他妈酷，是一个伟大而酷的人。所以就这样。我们可以继续了。等等，我得，我得，我得告诉我的肖恩。嘿，故事。我们开始吧。这是一个很棒的故事。现在，肖恩，我告诉过你这个吗？我不知道。我告诉过你我被邀请在《威尔和格蕾丝》里演一个角色吗？好吧。你不记得这个了，因为它只持续了一个早上。你参加剧本朗读了吗？我没有参加剧本朗读。好吧。好吧。所以告诉我我是否说对了。所以我家里有小孩。是你的吗？我当时正在和戴维·克罗斯写一部电影
and all my friends, Mr. Show Movie. And I was having a great time, but I was also exhausted, you know, and you have little babies. Run, run, run. Yeah. It was run, run, run sketch movie. We were writing a bunch of attempts. And so I was really enjoying that, but also exhausted, all the time exhausted, little baby at home, first kid. And so they said, they want you to do Will and Grace. And it's great. You know, great show and okay, cool. And I get up, I do my normal morning. I'm taking my son. We would go on a spider walk in the morning where he'd sit in my arm, the crook of my arm, and we'd walk around the house and look for spider webs. And he'd go, he'd go, when he saw a spider web, and we'd just walk around the house every morning with Will
和我所有的朋友，《短剧秀》电影。我玩得很开心，但我也精疲力竭，你知道，你有小宝宝。跑，跑，跑。是的，那是跑，跑，跑短剧电影。我们正在写很多尝试。所以我真的很享受那个，但也精疲力竭，一直精疲力竭，家里有小宝宝，第一个孩子。所以他们说，他们想让你演《威尔和格蕾丝》。而且这很棒。你知道，很棒的节目，好吧，酷。我起床，我做我正常的早晨。我带着我的儿子。我们会在早上进行蜘蛛漫步，他会坐在我的手臂里，手臂的弯处，我们会绕着房子走，寻找蜘蛛网。他会发出，他会发出，当他看到蜘蛛网时，我们每天早上都会绕着房子走，和威尔
sometime. Yeah. I'm so surprised you can carry. And then I'm halfway through my little spider walk. And I think, I think I have to be on Will and Grace, like right now. Oh shit. Oh my God. You mean you just didn't show up? No, I finished the walk quickly. I grabbed clothes. I was wearing my pajamas, got in my car, drove to the studio, changed in the bathroom, parked my car, changed in the bathroom, not hadn't shaved, hadn't showered, ran in late. So you're describing Jason like to a tea. Did the reading, like a reading and then went to do the thing and I was so not there. I was so not there. So it was like a table or like, or like, no, no, like the morning read, you know, I guess like you read it, we read it in the group and then we immediately went to the set to try to,
有时。是的。我很惊讶你能背着。然后我在我的小蜘蛛漫步中途。我想，我想我必须在《威尔和格蕾丝》里，就像现在。哦，该死。哦，天哪。你的意思是你就没出现？不，我很快结束了散步。我抓起衣服。我穿着睡衣，上了车，开车去摄影棚，在浴室里换衣服，停好车，在浴室里换衣服，没刮胡子，没洗澡，迟到了。所以你描述杰森就像描述得一模一样。做了朗读，就像一次朗读，然后去做了那件事，我根本不在状态。我根本不在状态。所以就像剧本朗读，或者像，不，不，就像早上的朗读，你知道，我想就像你读它，我们在小组里读它，然后我们立刻去片场尝试，
you know, put it on. I do remember that. I do remember. And I was terrible and I'm thinking I'm terrible and I don't know. I forgot. This is like 20 years ago. Yes. Yes. I, my 22 year old son just who was on my arm just walked through this room. Spider check. Looking for spiders? Still looking for spiders. He's like, I got one. He's an arachnologist. That's crazy. Well, I'm sorry that it didn't work out that afternoon. I'm at the writer's office. My agent calls. I'm sitting with David Cross and Scott Ackerman and all these guys and I pick it up and they go, Hey, Bob, we got to talk to you. And I go, what? They're letting me go. And he goes, well, it's about Will and Grace. I go, they don't want me. They didn't feel like it worked out. I go, okay.
你知道，把它演出来。我确实记得。我确实记得。我演得很糟糕，我想我演得很糟糕，我不知道。我忘了。这大概是20年前的事了。是的。是的。我22岁的儿子，刚才还在我手臂上的那个，刚刚走过这个房间。蜘蛛检查。寻找蜘蛛？还在寻找蜘蛛。他说，我抓到一个。他是蜘蛛学家。这太疯狂了。好吧，我很抱歉那天下午没成功。我在编剧办公室。我的经纪人打电话来。我和戴维·克罗斯、斯科特·奥克曼和所有这些人坐在一起，我接起来，他们说，嘿，鲍勃，我们得和你谈谈。我说，什么？他们要解雇我。他说，好吧，是关于《威尔和格蕾丝》的。我说，他们不想要我。他们觉得没成功。我说，好吧。
You're like, I didn't either. Gotta go. No. Well, gosh, I'm sorry that happened. And then no, don't be sorry. It was my fault completely. I just didn't prioritize acting at the time. I really, I don't think it adds up, but, but there's a connection. I remember that story you were talking about the guy who showed you the guy you had fired off Will and Grace, just to prove that you had the power to fire somebody. Didn't you have a story about that? It was about 20 years ago. Yeah. No, that's right. That's right. Let's move on. You know, I really just didn't prioritize acting at all. I acting was something that I like. I did a little of it in college. I did a play when I first moved to Chicago called Line by
你就像，我也不觉得。得走了。不。好吧，天哪，我很抱歉发生了那种事。然后不，别抱歉。完全是我的错。我当时只是没有把表演放在首位。我真的，我不认为这加起来，但，但有一个联系。我记得你说的那个故事，关于那个把你从《威尔和格蕾丝》里解雇的家伙，只是为了证明你有解雇某人的权力。你没有关于那个的故事吗？那是大约20年前的事了。是的。不，那是对的。那是对的。我们继续吧。你知道，我真的只是根本没有把表演放在首位。表演是我喜欢的。我在大学里做了一点。我刚搬到芝加哥时演了一部戏，叫《线》，作者是
Israel Horowitz, kind of a famous play because Pacino, I guess, did it for a long time. And and it ran for like 15 years. Pacino actor from the Godfather. And it, it just wasn't something, you know, I was so thankful I could work as a writer. You stopped, you wanted to write more, and then you directed these movies. You made, let's go to prison. We made Brother Salman and you were talking at that time that this is what you wanted to do. You wanted to focus more on directing and writing. I love directing. Yeah. But then your life takes a change and all of a sudden acting becomes not just part of it, becomes the main focus and the last 10, 12 years you have become an incredibly good enough celebrated. No, fuck that. Now, are you finding that a lot of
以色列·霍洛维茨，算是一部著名的戏，因为帕西诺，我想，演了很长时间。而且它演了大概15年。帕西诺，《教父》里的演员。而且它，它只是不是什么，你知道，我很感激我能当编剧。你停下来了，你想写更多，然后你导演了这些电影。你拍了《去监狱吧》。我们拍了《所罗门兄弟》，你当时说这就是你想做的。你想更多地专注于导演和写作。我喜欢导演。是的。但后来你的生活发生了变化，突然间表演不仅成了它的一部分，成了主要焦点，过去12年你已经成为了一名令人难以置信的、足够受赞誉的。不，去他妈的。现在，你是否发现很多
opportunity is coming your way maybe through like sort of like this sexy indifference or, or are you really pointing towards acting and not really looking at writing and directing as much? Oh, I'm, I'm writing a lot. Yeah, I'm writing a lot, but not directing. You know what? Listen, when I walked away from actually it was a small indie movie I made called Melvin Goes to Dinner that in a way was the most successful film I made because it made people happy. It played very well at some film festivals and won the audience awarded South by Southwest and that was a great screening, a great experience for me. But you know, I walked away from those movies, Will, and I thought the first job of a director is to pick a story that you really, really want to tell, that you did just,
机会正向你走来，也许通过某种像这种性感的冷漠，或者，或者你真的倾向于表演，而不是真的像以前那样关注写作和导演？哦，我，我写了很多。是的，我写了很多，但不导演。你知道吗？听着，当我离开我拍的一部叫《梅尔文去吃晚餐》的小型独立电影时，在某种程度上那是我拍过的最成功的电影，因为它让人们快乐。它在一些电影节上放映得很好，并赢得了西南偏南电影节的观众奖，那是一次很棒的放映，对我来说是一次很棒的经历。但你知道，我离开了那些电影，威尔，我想导演的第一份工作是选择一个你真正、真正想讲的故事，你只是，
you have a strong sense of how it should be told because you take the hit when it doesn't work. I mean, you feel it, you fuck that up. You are the core reason why that didn't work. So I thought, okay, your first job is picking a story that you just have to tell and that you know, you may be wrong, but you have a strong sense of how it should be told. And I would say, with Melvin Goes to Dinner, it was a play that I saw and I thought, well, this is a fun play, the dialogue is what matters and it's kind of really great, got this great energy to it and we'll keep this cast together and we'll shoot it with five cameras and everyone can keep their kind of very lively interactions and energy. It can be sustained and brought to the screen this way
你对它应该如何讲述有强烈的感知，因为当它不奏效时，你得承担后果。我的意思是，你感觉到了，你他妈搞砸了。你是那件事没奏效的核心原因。所以我认为，好吧，你的第一份工作是选择一个你必须讲的故事，而且你知道，你可能是错的，但你对它应该如何讲述有强烈的感知。我会说，对于《梅尔文去吃晚餐》，那是我看过的一部戏，我想，好吧，这是一部有趣的戏，对话才是最重要的，它真的很棒，有这种很棒的能量，我们会保持这个演员阵容，我们会用五台摄像机拍摄，每个人都可以保持他们那种非常生动的互动和能量。它可以被维持并以这种方式带到银幕上
and that was true. And then let's go to prison, had this gritty, tough underbelly to it and I thought we'll shoot it like a 70s B movie. We'll do these snap zooms and we'll get some 16 millimeter film and I had some strong visual sense of what it should be. And that was pretty good. It has some integrity to it. And then Brother Solomon, I was just, it was like I was a jobber. I was just trying to bring that script alive. And later when I saw Last Man on Earth, Forte's series, I thought those guys really figured out a kind of a way to do Forte's writing that I've enjoyed very much. I love that show. Wait, can I go back for a second? Melvin goes to dinner. Are you saying you used the cast from the play in the movie? Yes. Okay. Cast from the play. God bless you because I love you for that.
那是真的。然后《去监狱吧》，有这种坚韧、艰难的底色，我想我们会像70年代的B级片那样拍摄它。我们会做这些快速变焦，我们会弄一些16毫米胶片，我对它应该是什么样子有一些强烈的视觉感知。那还不错。它有一些完整性。然后《所罗门兄弟》，我只是，就像我是一个打工仔。我只是试图让那个剧本活起来。后来当我看到《最后一个男人》，福特的系列剧时，我想那些家伙真的找到了一种方式来做福特的写作，我非常喜欢。我喜欢那个节目。等等，我可以回去一秒钟吗？《梅尔文去吃晚餐》。你是说你用了戏里的演员来拍电影？是的。好吧。戏里的演员。上帝保佑你，因为我为此爱你。
I think that is amazing because you go see these plays, I won't name which ones that turn into these huge movies, that you're like, well, they just nailed it on stage. Why wouldn't you just use those actors? I'm probably talking myself out of a future job, but why don't you just use those actors? They're so fantastic, so good on you. I think that's amazing. Well, thanks for saying that. You know, speaking of a great actor who was in a play and is now getting some attention, a guy I knew in Chicago named Paul Racy is in Sound of Metal. Oh, great. Yeah. And he's so great. Is that the sequel to the Julie Andrews? It is. It is. Wow, that sounds interesting. Hey, when you are not putting 14-hour days under your belt on Better Call Saul,
我认为这太棒了，因为你去看了这些戏，我不会说出哪些变成了这些巨大的电影，你会想，好吧，他们在舞台上表现得太棒了。为什么你不直接用那些演员？我可能在劝自己放弃未来的工作，但为什么你不直接用那些演员？他们太棒了，所以为你点赞。我认为这太棒了。好吧，谢谢你这么说。你知道，说到一个在戏里表现出色现在正受到关注的伟大演员，我在芝加哥认识的一个叫保罗·雷西的家伙在《金属之声》里。哦，太棒了。是的。而且他太棒了。那是朱莉·安德鲁斯的续集吗？是的。是的。哇，那听起来很有趣。嘿，当你没有在《风骚律师》里每天工作14个小时时，
do you like to completely do nothing in the entertainment industry? And if so, what is that? No, I never do nothing. I'm always writing. David Cross and I and my brother Bill are writing a kind of a big, sprawling comic documentary epic right now that we hope somebody will want. And I'm working on so many projects, a drama about OxyContin and a comedy. I wrote an animated show with Dino San Botopoulos where the devil moves into a town near Indianapolis. And I just, I'm always writing. I have a memoir coming out next year, too. And I wrote a book with my daughter, you know, during this COVID time. No weird creepy hobbies aside from spider hunting. No, I work out a lot now because I made this action movie called Nobody. Dude,
你喜欢在娱乐业里完全什么都不做吗？如果是这样，那是什么？不，我从不什么都不做。我一直在写作。戴维·克罗斯和我以及我的兄弟比尔正在写一种大型的、庞大的喜剧纪录片史诗，我们希望有人会想要。我正在做很多项目，一部关于奥施康定的剧情片和一部喜剧。我和迪诺·圣·波托普洛斯写了一部动画节目，魔鬼搬到了印第安纳波利斯附近的一个小镇。我只是，我一直在写作。我明年还有一本回忆录要出版。而且我在这个新冠疫情期间和我女儿写了一本书。除了蜘蛛狩猎，没有奇怪的令人毛骨悚然的爱好。不，我现在锻炼很多，因为我拍了这部动作片叫《小人物》。伙计，
I saw the trailer. It looks amazing. Bob, I wanted to ask you about that. It's so fucking great. What's it called again? It's called Nobody. Is that two words? It's one word. Well, I was just thinking because he worked out, you know, and nobody. Thanks. Sure. No problem, dude. You know, puns. Listen, you can start the audience with a laugh. They're coming back. Yeah. They're coming back along with parades. Consider be ready. Jason's memoir has come out next year, too. It's called My Life in Puns. So, Bob, the fucking trailer for this movie, all of a sudden, like you literally have a line where you're on a bus and you're faced up against these tough guys. You go, I'm going to fuck you up. Well, that was, you know, that was a monologue.
我看了预告片。看起来太棒了。鲍勃，我想问你关于那个的事。真是他妈的太棒了。它叫什么来着？它叫《小人物》。那是两个词吗？是一个词。好吧，我只是在想，因为他锻炼了，你知道，在《小人物》里。谢谢。当然。没问题，伙计。你知道，双关语。听着，你可以用笑声开始观众。他们会回来的。是的。他们会和游行队伍一起回来。考虑准备好。杰森的回忆录明年也要出版了。叫《我的双关语人生》。所以，鲍勃，这部电影的他妈的预告片，突然间，你真的有一句台词，你在公共汽车上，你面对这些强硬的家伙。你说，我要他妈的干掉你。好吧，那是，你知道，那是一段独白。
That was like a page and a half long monologue that Derek Colstead wrote who wrote the John Wick films. And he's a great writer and he writes these mythic worlds and bad guys from that's come out of the shadows and they're parts of big organizations that I can't tell you what they mean yet, but you'll find out. And that's, it's just, he's so great, this guy. I love hanging out with him. I love hearing his stories, but he had written this long monologue and it was like, the universe has a hell of a way of paying back what's owed and all this stuff. And I'm putting it off. You know, we're working with the story and he was really great talking to me about it because it kind of sprang from my own idea. The whole movie, because I had a couple of
那是一段大概一页半长的独白，是德里克·科尔斯塔德写的，他写了《疾速追杀》系列电影。他是一位伟大的编剧，他写了这些神话般的世界和坏人，他们从阴影中走出来，他们是大型组织的一部分，我还没法告诉你那意味着什么，但你会发现的。而且那，它只是，他太棒了，这个家伙。我喜欢和他一起玩。我喜欢听他的故事，但他写了这段长独白，就像，宇宙有一种该死的方式来偿还所欠的东西，所有这些东西。我一直在推迟。你知道，我们正在处理这个故事，他和我谈论这个时真的很棒，因为它有点源于我自己的想法。整部电影，因为我有几个
home break ins here in LA that left me with a lot of conflicted feelings. What kind of neighborhood are you in, Bob? Well, it's obviously not a deal on the house. I don't have that Netflix money. It sounds like you got a real deal on this place. Is it near prison? It comes with mathematics. That was so nobody came out of your own sort of feeling about a guy's going to fight back a little bit. It came out of a lot of ideas and thoughts I had, but one of them was the genuine feeling of like I, we had had this, we'd had two break ins, but one was particularly traumatic for my family and I didn't do anything like recent or it would have been 10 years ago, that one. And you were home when it happened? We were all home. Oh,
洛杉矶发生的入室盗窃案让我感到非常矛盾。鲍勃，你住在什么样的社区？好吧，显然这房子不是什么便宜货。我可没有网飞（Netflix）那种财力。听起来你这房子买得很划算啊。离监狱近吗？它还附带数学题。那并不是因为你内心深处觉得有人会反击。它源于我脑海中的许多想法和念头，其中之一就是一种真实的感觉，比如我，我们经历过，我们遭遇过两次入室盗窃，但其中一次对我家人来说特别痛苦，我当时什么也没做，或者说那是10年前的事了。事情发生时你在家吗？我们都在家。哦，
wow. Yeah. And it was very traumatic. Thank God you're okay. So I tried to keep things cool, you know, I'm not that I have any weapons. I mean, like any dad, I grabbed the baseball bat and I haven't swung a bat since I was 14. So, you know, it leaves you feeling like, gosh, I mean, what else could I have done? And what should I have done? And how should I be prepared? And, and, but if I had done something, what would have happened then, you know, and it really, I mean, it is smart to keep things cool and back off and get the hell out of there. Everyone's okay. Yeah. Well, there's a residual. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I'm sorry about that. For sure. So all that sits with you. And, and so I, you know, you just can't help but feel
哇。是的。那次经历非常痛苦。谢天谢地你没事。所以我尽量保持冷静，你知道，并不是说我有武器。我的意思是，像任何父亲一样，我抓起了一根棒球棍，但我从14岁起就没挥过棒球棍了。所以，你知道，这让你感觉，天哪，我还能做什么呢？我本该做什么？我该如何准备？而且，如果我真的做了什么，那会发生什么呢，你知道，保持冷静、后退并尽快离开那里确实是明智的。大家都平安无事。是的。好吧，还有一些残留的影响。当然。是的。好吧，对此我感到很抱歉。确实。所以这一切都萦绕在你心头。所以，你知道，你忍不住会产生
those feelings and ask those questions. And it stays with you, obviously. You think you probably think about it at least a few times a week. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I'm sure. And you think about guns, you know, which I'm like, definitely for stronger gun laws. But you think about what value are they? I mean, how would you have one safely in your home and then be able to use it? All these, all these complicated issues. But most of all, there's that personal frustration and anger. And I thought I'd like to work that out and see if there was a place for that in a story. And of course, there is in action movies. That's exactly what it's built out. They're built out of. And so I proposed this. I actually thought I'd get laughed out of the room, you know, but people
那些感受并提出那些问题。而且这显然会一直伴随着你。我想你可能每周至少会想到几次。哦，是的。是的，我肯定。你会想到枪支，你知道，我绝对支持更严格的枪支法。但你会想它们有什么价值？我的意思是，你怎么能在家里安全地拥有一把枪，然后又能使用它呢？所有这些复杂的问题。但最重要的是，那种个人的挫败感和愤怒。我想我希望能解决这个问题，看看故事里是否有它的位置。当然，动作电影里就有。这正是动作电影的构建基础。它们就是这样构建出来的。所以我提出了这个想法。我其实以为会被人嘲笑，你知道，但人们
were like, no, no. Actually, it also came from my brother in law. He was in China. And he took a picture of his TV screen, which had an ad for Better Call Saul. And I thought, shit, if they're watching me in China, and I know they show plays in Russia and Italy and all around the world, what could I make that would play around the world? Well, an action movie plays because we know what everybody wants on screen without understanding the language. And so there were so many things that drove me to ask, what about an action movie? I'm willing to do the training. And people said, yeah, that's a, yeah, that could work. So did you have to train because there's a lot of physical activity, like, like you do a lot of
却说，不，不。其实这也源于我的姐夫。他在中国。他拍了一张电视屏幕的照片，上面有《风骚律师》的广告。我想，该死，如果他们在中国都在看我，而且我知道我的剧在俄罗斯、意大利和世界各地都有播放，我能做出什么能在全球播放的作品呢？好吧，动作电影行得通，因为我们知道每个人在屏幕上想看什么，而不需要理解语言。所以有太多的事情促使我问，动作电影怎么样？我愿意接受训练。人们说，是的，那，那行得通。所以你必须接受训练吗？因为有很多体力活动，比如，你做了很多
I mean, listen, Jason, yeah, I do all my own fighting in this movie. Good Lord. Wow. I trained for two years. It's a lot. It's a lot. I pull muscles getting out of bed. Did you, did you have a, I mean, the first goal of the training was that I don't get hurt when I do the fight. Was that successful? It was pretty successful. I didn't, what happens is you train sort of just the basics for a year and a half while this whole project was being put together, you know, it takes years always. So I had a long time, but I was training for a long time. And then, then you put the pieces up in the gym and you choreograph them and you learn the choreography over and over. But then when you get on set, things change. And of course, the set is maybe
我的意思是，听着，杰森，是的，这部电影里所有的打斗都是我自己完成的。天哪。哇。我训练了两年。这很多。这很多。我下床都会拉伤肌肉。你，你有没有，我的意思是，训练的第一个目标是我在打斗时不会受伤。成功了吗？相当成功。我没有，发生的情况是，当整个项目还在筹备时，你大概花了一年半的时间训练基础动作，你知道，这总是需要几年时间。所以我有很多时间，但我训练了很长时间。然后，然后你在健身房把动作拼凑起来，编排它们，一遍又一遍地学习编排。但当你到了片场，事情就变了。当然，片场可能
dimension wise, it can be a little different than what you trained in. And of course, now everything is real. The walls are walls. They're not cardboard boxes. And so you end up hitting, I only got hurt a little by hitting my fists on metal bars and stuff that were in that bus fight. The bus fight is really something. The bus fight is insane. By the way, I didn't want to interrupt. I don't know if you ever heard the story about Jason cut his finger taking his golf clubs out of his Tesla, but yeah, it was, it was, we had, we thought about having a sequence where I take golf clubs out of a Tesla and we talked about, we couldn't get the insurance. Right, right. Just not believe a rehearsal for that. You've probably heard, you've also probably heard this
在尺寸上可能和你训练的地方有点不同。当然，现在一切都是真实的。墙就是墙。它们不是纸板箱。所以你最终会受伤，我只是因为在公交车打斗中撞到金属杆之类的东西而受了一点伤。那场公交车打斗真的很棒。公交车打斗太疯狂了。顺便说一句，我不想打断你。我不知道你是否听说过杰森从特斯拉里拿高尔夫球杆时切断手指的故事，但是的，我们确实考虑过安排一个我从特斯拉里拿高尔夫球杆的镜头，我们讨论过，但我们没能搞定保险。对，对。那只是个排练。你可能也听说过这个
story about Jason had to bring an icy hot patch for my tender back the other day over to my house. You know, Jason, I love your attitude about it because another actor whose name I won't mention, I met him at one of these things we used to do before a pandemic destroyed social interaction in the world. And I go, yeah, I'm training. I'm training. I've been training for a year and a half. And he looks at me and he goes, why? They have stuntmen who will do that for you. He was mystified. And I think you are too. You're like, don't you know you're in show business, Bob? You don't actually have to do anything to say the lines. I just know at my age, 52, you pull a little thing in your back or something. Okay. Yeah. Just little tweaks.
关于杰森前几天不得不给我那酸痛的背部带一片冰热贴的故事。你知道，杰森，我喜欢你对此的态度，因为另一位我不便透露姓名的演员，我在疫情摧毁世界社交互动之前参加的活动中见过他。我说，是的，我在训练。我在训练。我已经训练了一年半了。他看着我说，为什么？他们有替身演员会为你做这些。他感到很困惑。我想你也是。你就像是，鲍勃，你不知道你在演艺圈吗？你其实不需要做任何事，只要念台词就行了。我只是知道在我这个年纪，52岁，你背部拉伤一点点什么的。好吧。是的。只是小伤。
They last weeks. You're right. You're in good shape. You take, I give you shit, but you take care of yourself. The thing is, if you've never, if you've never wrecked your knees or your back, then you can get in shape enough to do that these things. I had knee surgery four years ago and I tweaked my back, but I'm never giving up. I don't give a shit. I mean, this fucking chassis was made to fucking run. Yeah, look at you. But wait, so, so, Bob, how fucking crazy is that? And you had, you had like a real bonafide from top to bottom action people involved in this, from the writing to the other producers. I know Dave Leach a little bit who was involved with the film too. Yeah, David Leach. He's a fucking cool guy. And I trained at 87.11 his gym
它们会持续几周。你说得对。你状态不错。你，我虽然损你，但你照顾得很好。问题是，如果你从来没有弄坏过膝盖或背部，那么你就能练出足够的体能来做这些事情。我四年前做过膝盖手术，也拉伤过背部，但我从不放弃。我才不管呢。我的意思是，这副该死的底盘就是为了奔跑而生的。是的，看看你。但等等，所以，所以，鲍勃，这有多疯狂？而且你还有，你还有像真正从头到尾的动作专业人士参与其中，从编剧到其他制片人。我认识一点戴夫·里奇，他也参与了这部电影。是的，大卫·里奇。他是个超级酷的家伙。我在他的健身房87.11训练
and Daniel Bernhardt, the best stunt actor in the world. Daniel Bernhardt trained me for that whole time and I don't know why he did, but he was willing to do it. Bob, you know, we'll, we'll mention this at the top of the interview that, you know, you just work constantly, you wear so many hats. Where does that come from in the drive? And I asked that a lot of our guests, but I think it's fascinating because you look at all the stuff that you accomplish is like, wow, and you have this family. It's like, how do you fit it all in? Let me finish my thought from earlier, which was about directly. Stop cutting him off, Sean. Sorry. Which was just this, you know, I'm not sure I'll ever find a story that I think I like and can commit to enough to want to direct
还有丹尼尔·伯恩哈特，世界上最好的特技演员。丹尼尔·伯恩哈特在那段时间里训练了我，我不知道他为什么这么做，但他愿意这样做。鲍勃，你知道，我们会在采访开头提到，你知道，你一直在工作，你身兼数职。这种动力从何而来？我经常问我们的嘉宾这个问题，但我认为这很迷人，因为你看看你取得的所有成就，就像，哇，而且你还有这个家庭。就像，你是怎么兼顾这一切的？让我完成我之前的想法，关于导演。别再打断他了，肖恩。抱歉。这只是，你知道，我不确定我是否能找到一个我认为我喜欢并且能投入足够多精力去想导演的故事
again. As much as I love directing, I think directing is probably the most rewarding thing any of us can do if we get to do it. You get to use all your talents as a storyteller and it's just the best. It's really rewarding. But if I'm too much of a bird brain hopping from stick to stick and I can't focus long enough or really care deeply enough about a story, I probably shouldn't direct and I so far haven't done it and I'm not really chasing it. It'll find you. But you can't rule it out. But the thing is, I don't really have hobbies. I read books. And you love work. I like what I do. I like doing what I do. I like thinking about stories and how to make them work. The thing is, I don't want to be a dilettante. I don't want to
再次尝试。尽管我热爱导演，但我认为导演可能是我们所有人能做的最有回报的事情，如果我们有机会做的话。你可以发挥你作为讲故事者的所有才能，这真是太棒了。这真的很有回报。但如果我像个鸟脑子一样从一根树枝跳到另一根树枝，无法长时间专注，或者无法真正深入地关心一个故事，我可能就不应该导演，到目前为止我还没这样做，我也没有真正追求它。它会找到你的。但你不能排除这种可能性。但问题是，我真的没有爱好。我读书。而且你热爱工作。我喜欢我所做的事情。我喜欢做我正在做的事。我喜欢思考故事以及如何让它们奏效。问题是，我不想成为一个业余爱好者。我不想
be George Plimpton, which is one of the reasons why I did train for this movie and I wanted to do my own fighting. And thanks to the team at 87.11 and the people who got me there, I was able to do that and you can see that I do it. And I did it, I think well enough. People will decide. They may tell me I'm wrong. What do you think about when you see Tom Cruise hanging from an airplane? I look at that and go, God, I wish I had the sack to do that. Was that something that you would do? Well, that's different from doing the fighting. That's just taking a big risk. Right. But I mean, as far as the efforts made for authenticity and doing your own stuff. I mean, I gotta say, I'll take that guy on.
成为乔治·普林普顿，这也是我为这部电影进行训练的原因之一，我想自己完成打斗。多亏了87.11的团队和那些帮助我的人，我能够做到这一点，你可以看到我做到了。而且我认为我做得足够好。人们会做出评判。他们可能会告诉我我错了。当你看到汤姆·克鲁斯挂在飞机上时，你怎么想？我看着那个心想，天哪，我希望我有那个胆量去做。那是你会做的事情吗？好吧，那和做打斗不同。那只是冒巨大的风险。对。但我的意思是，就为了真实感和自己完成动作所做的努力而言。我的意思是，我得说，我会接受那个挑战。
Oh, yeah. There we go. You heard it here first, guys. It's fucking on. Bob, I want to go back and say, because it's the thing we kind of glossed over. But of course you have it. And you just mentioned you're working with him again with your brother as well. But you have a long, long friendship and working relationship with somebody who I love very much. I know Jason loves very much. And Sean, I think you know, and he's just a guy that big part of my life, big part of my professional life, certainly, and just an awesome guy, David Cross. Can you talk a little bit about your relationship with David and what a fucking huge impact you
哦，是的。就是这样。伙计们，你们在这里先听到了。这该死的开始了。鲍勃，我想回去说一下，因为这是我们有点略过的事情。但你当然有它。你刚才提到你又和你的兄弟一起与他合作了。但你和某个人有着长期、长期的友谊和工作关系，我非常爱他。我知道杰森也非常爱他。肖恩，我想你也认识，他就是我生命中很重要的一部分，当然也是我职业生涯中很重要的一部分，而且是一个很棒的家伙，大卫·克罗斯。你能谈谈你和大卫的关系，以及你们对喜剧产生了多么巨大的影响吗？
guys had on comedy. Well, that's nice. Thanks. I hope we helped some people and made a lot of people laugh. But I mean, people always give Mr. Show credit for this, like the way it was constructed. And I'm like, yeah, but it was really funny. That's what was good about it. Who gives a shit? But I think that that's sort of a nod to the sort of people appreciating that you guys, you guys did something that was complicated and you didn't need to, right? Like you made a bunch of people laugh on one frequency, but then you guys kept writing all these other frequencies that were much more challenging, tough to see just the thread, right? Just that basic concept
好吧，那太好了。谢谢。我希望我们帮助了一些人，并让很多人笑了。但我的意思是，人们总是把《Mr. Show》的功劳归功于此，比如它的结构方式。而我说，是的，但它真的很有趣。这就是它的好之处。谁在乎呢？但我认为这是一种对人们欣赏你们的致敬，你们做了一些复杂的事情，而且你们本不需要这样做，对吧？就像你们让一群人在一个频率上大笑，但随后你们又写了所有其他频率更高、更具挑战性的东西，很难看出其中的线索，对吧？只是那个基本概念
of the thread between Iska might go right over a lot of people's heads that are fully satisfied with that show. You know, I think it's really, it's admirable. You know, this is a weird thing. And that show was the best thing I could do with my life, as far as I'm concerned. And that goes for looking back on it. And I'm thankful for Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul and all this stuff. But that show, as far as I'm concerned, defines me and my sensibility. And I don't know if I could do anything more me than that show in this lifetime. So it's a weird thing to have done that, feel good about it, feel like you did enough of it, you know, like that it was substantial, and then just be like, oh, I guess whatever I do next,
线索之间的联系可能直接从很多对那个节目完全满意的人头上飞过。你知道，我认为这真的很令人钦佩。你知道，这是一件奇怪的事情。就我而言，那个节目是我一生中能做的最好的事情。回顾过去也是如此。我很感谢《绝命毒师》和《风骚律师》以及所有这些东西。但就我而言，那个节目定义了我，定义了我的感性。我不知道在这个有生之年我还能不能做出比那个节目更像我的东西。所以，做过那件事，对它感觉良好，觉得你做得足够多了，你知道，觉得它很有实质性，然后只是觉得，哦，我想无论我接下来做什么，
I don't know, whatever is most interesting, but that's, it's never going to be as fully me as that. And how fortunate that the first big high profile thing that you do as a performer is accurately portraying your brand of comedy. In other words, you didn't have to do a series of jobs afterwards to sort of reset a more accurate description and representation of what you would like to do and how you would like to be identified in the comedy world. Like it was right on brand, what the kind of funny you'd like to give. And then you just kind of took that and ran with it, yes? Yeah, yeah, for sure. Yeah, a lot of people don't get that. Yeah, a lot of people never get it, not once. And so it's funny because I'm writing this memoir and it's mostly about Mr. Show.
我不知道，无论什么最有趣，但那，它永远不会像那个节目那样完全是我。而且，你作为表演者做的第一件高调的事情就是准确地描绘了你的喜剧品牌，这是多么幸运啊。换句话说，你不需要在之后做一系列的工作来重新设定一个更准确的描述和代表，关于你想做什么以及你想在喜剧世界中如何被识别。就像它完全符合品牌，是你喜欢给予的那种幽默。然后你就顺着它做了，对吧？是的，是的，当然。是的，很多人不明白这一点。是的，很多人永远不明白，一次都没有。所以这很有趣，因为我正在写这本回忆录，它主要关于《Mr. Show》。
Yeah. Oh, cool. Yeah, both you and David held on to that really difficult kind of subversive, you know, street cred punk rock type of comedy that. And in the same way that Monty Python kind of did, it's interesting that that's one of your inspirations because maybe you, I don't know if you think, but just to, sorry, Jason, finish your thought a little bit. It's like, you know, I grew up in the same way. I just, I revered Monty Python. I just, I watched every single episode and it was, it was amazing, but that you created this thing called Mr. Show that now has the kind of same kind of impact on the comedy world that that did for that generation. I really think that you've accomplished that. You and David. Yeah, all that's nice to hear. I've had people say
是的。哦，酷。是的，你和大卫都坚持那种非常困难的、颠覆性的、你知道，街头信誉朋克摇滚类型的喜剧。就像蒙提·派森（Monty Python）所做的那样，有趣的是那是你的灵感来源之一，因为也许你，我不知道你是否认为，但只是为了，抱歉，杰森，完成你的想法。就像，你知道，我是在同样的方式下长大的。我只是，我崇拜蒙提·派森。我只是，我看了每一集，它，它太棒了，但你创造了这个叫《Mr. Show》的东西，现在它在喜剧界产生了和那个对那一代人一样的冲击力。我真的认为你已经实现了这一点。你和大卫。是的，听到这些都很好。我曾听人说过
similar things, but obviously Python influenced such a huge generation and, and also was able to get more absurdist than we got. We just aren't, we don't think that way. But I love that show and I even love its absurdisms, but although the season without Cleese is my least favorite season. Where did Benny Hill sit for you in the, in the English sort of absurdist comedy world? Behind the toilet. No, I did laugh at Benny Hill a bit, but I actually was, Benny Hill, it's not the most egregious example of a certain kind of comedy that we all shared in, in the seventies that really irked me on a deep level. It really unsettled me. I think as a kid growing up in a house with an alcoholic father and it took a while for us to find out
类似的话，但显然派森影响了如此巨大的一代人，而且也能够比我们更荒诞。我们只是不是，我们不那样想。但我喜欢那个节目，我甚至喜欢它的荒诞，尽管没有克里斯的那一季是我最不喜欢的一季。本尼·希尔（Benny Hill）在英国那种荒诞喜剧世界里对你来说处于什么位置？在马桶后面。不，我确实对本尼·希尔笑过一点，但我实际上是，本尼·希尔，它不是我们在七十年代共享的某种喜剧的最恶劣的例子，它真的在深层上让我感到厌烦。它真的让我感到不安。我想作为一个在酗酒父亲的家庭中长大的孩子，我们花了一段时间才发现
what was going on. You know, I was probably about 12 or 13 when I understood what the thing was that made our house weird and wrong and fucked up and kind of really deeply unsettling. Like, I think this thing's going to break apart tomorrow morning at any moment. For the same feeling. And that comedy of the seventies and my dad loved He-Haw, which is so crazy because later my manager was Bernie Brillstein who helped make He-Haw, which I hated so much. I hated it so much. Anyway, this, this comedy of the seventies, I think everyone was so, I don't know, I'll psychoanalyze the whole nation. You know, Vietnam was so brutal and left so many raw nerves, right? And so this comedy came in
发生了什么。你知道，我大概12或13岁时才明白是什么让我们的家变得奇怪、错误、混乱，而且在某种程度上非常令人不安。就像，我想这东西明天早上随时都会分崩离析。同样的感觉。七十年代的喜剧，我爸爸喜欢《He-Haw》，这太疯狂了，因为后来我的经纪人是伯尼·布里尔斯坦，他帮助制作了《He-Haw》，我非常讨厌它。我非常讨厌它。总之，这种七十年代的喜剧，我想每个人都太，我不知道，我会对整个国家进行心理分析。你知道，越南战争太残酷了，留下了太多的伤口，对吧？所以这种喜剧进来了
of Oh God, John Denver, George Burns, both wonderful people, I'm sure. And I love, I got to meet George Burns. I loved meeting him. But there was this grotesque, super sweet, you know, fake phony, everything's okay. We're just joking around up here. I really, that I just hated so much. And of course, SNL was a breath of fresh air. It was dangerous. It was a little more confrontational. It didn't apologize, you know? I mean, that whole thing with the Dean Martin Rose, which I laughed at, absolutely. But also there was just this side to that whole thing that was like crude comment, kind of almost maybe slightly racist comment. And then like, we're all just friends. We love each other. It's all life is sweet. And it just felt awful to me.
哦天哪，约翰·丹佛，乔治·伯恩斯，我相信他们都是很棒的人。我喜欢，我有幸见到了乔治·伯恩斯。我喜欢见到他。但有一种怪诞的、超级甜蜜的，你知道，虚假的、虚伪的，一切都好。我们只是在这里开玩笑。我真的，我非常讨厌那个。当然，SNL（周六夜现场）是一股清新的空气。它很危险。它更具对抗性。它不道歉，你知道？我的意思是，迪恩·马丁吐槽大会（Dean Martin Roast）的那整件事，我确实笑了，绝对。但也有那种整件事的一面，就像粗俗的评论，几乎可能是轻微的种族主义评论。然后就像，我们都是朋友。我们彼此相爱。生活是甜蜜的。这对我来说感觉太糟糕了。
Sort of lowest common denominator, humor, if you will. And people were trying to come together, I think in a really strange and artificial way, they were trying to get back, get the nation back together or something or could soothe their nerves after this horrific 10 years of Vietnam and bloodshed. So this hippie-ish, like it was trying to bring the hippie culture into mainstream culture. Remember the Pinto car that had Levi's seats? Yeah. Oh, wow. That's right. Remember that? Yeah. Remember, that's incredible. Yeah. I love that show. Sarah Purcell. John Davidson and friend Tarkin. What was the one Fred Willard was on? Real people? Real people. Real people. You know, it was like this attempt by the whole country to like calm down. It's okay. We're just
某种最低共同分母的幽默，如果你愿意的话。人们试图以一种非常奇怪和人为的方式走到一起，我想他们试图回到，让国家重新团结起来或者什么，或者在经历了这可怕的十年越南战争和流血事件后安抚他们的神经。所以这种嬉皮士风格，就像它试图把嬉皮文化带入主流文化。还记得有李维斯（Levi's）座椅的平托（Pinto）车吗？是的。哦，哇。没错。还记得那个吗？是的。还记得，那太不可思议了。是的。我喜欢那个节目。莎拉·珀塞尔。约翰·戴维森和朋友塔金。弗雷德·威拉德参加的是哪一个？《Real People》？《Real People》。你知道，这就像整个国家试图冷静下来。没关系。我们只是
quirky. We're not dangerous. We don't have strong feelings. We're just quirky. We're just a bunch of quirky people. And quirky is okay. And part of me, you know, I mean, a big part of me as a kid is like, it's no, we're not just quirky people. We're, we're different. And there's something really bad happened. Somebody say it, you know, and yeah, yeah, I see that. I see the connection you're making. And I think that probably informed a lot of like kind of what you did and what you guys ended up doing on, on Mr. Show and sort of hitting. I think the best comedy does that. Yeah. You know, Eric, Eric Idle in his book talks about seeing the fringe, the beyond the fringe guys, you know, Peter Cook and Dudley Moore. And I forget the other two also great writers.
古怪。我们不危险。我们没有强烈的感情。我们只是一群古怪的人。古怪没关系。而我的一部分，你知道，我的意思是，作为一个孩子，我很大一部分是，不，我们不仅仅是古怪的人。我们，我们不同。而且发生了一些非常糟糕的事情。有人说出来，你知道，是的，是的，我看到了。我看到了你建立的联系。而且我认为这可能影响了很多你所做的，以及你们最终在《Mr. Show》上所做的，并击中。我认为最好的喜剧就是这样。是的。你知道，埃里克·艾德尔（Eric Idle）在他的书中谈到了看到边缘（Fringe）的人，超越边缘（Beyond the Fringe）的人，你知道，彼得·库克（Peter Cook）和达德利·摩尔（Dudley Moore）。我忘了另外两个也是伟大的作家。
And he said seeing it as like in college, this was comedy with anger in it. And I agree. I agree that comedy should be a little bit unsettling, really great comedy. It should be a little serious about itself. It's got to be, there has to be, like you just said, there's an element of danger and there needs to be an element of surprise. Anybody who's ever, for me personally, maybe laugh, they always say something that's really, they surprise you in a way that you, in just by definition that you weren't expecting. And I remember, I remember McKay, Adam McKay once saying, describing somebody who I won't mention, who's very famous and saying, yeah, he's not, I was like, that guy bugs me. He says, yeah, because he's got zero surprise to him. And I was
他说在大学里看到它就像这是带有愤怒的喜剧。我同意。我同意喜剧应该有点令人不安，真正伟大的喜剧。它应该对自己有点严肃。它必须是，必须有，就像你刚才说的，有一个危险的元素，并且需要有一个惊喜的元素。任何曾经，对我个人而言，让我笑的人，他们总是说一些真正的东西，他们以一种你，仅仅根据定义你没预料到的方式让你感到惊讶。我记得，我记得麦凯，亚当·麦凯曾经说过，描述一个我不便透露姓名的人，他非常出名，说，是的，他不是，我当时想，那家伙让我烦。他说，是的，因为他对他来说零惊喜。而我当时
like, yes, that's exactly it. And, and by the way, street cred, we used to call it when we, the first season of unarrested, anytime we would like go to do something, you know, David would go, Cross would go like, man, that's lame, blah, blah, blah. And Jason and I would go, hey, street cred, what should we do that's cool? He kept us on our toes. Arrested development is a great example of a show that, you know, I consider that a height of comedy and it doesn't apologize or hold your hand. I mean, you really have to pay attention. Oh, and even for us making it, I mean, we constantly had to ask mature wits for, you know, comedic interpretation on all these incredibly smart things he was writing. I mean, everything existed on multiple levels that you'd need 14 layers of
就像，是的，就是这样。顺便说一句，街头信誉，我们过去常叫它，当我们，第一季的《发展受阻》（Arrested Development），每当我们想去做某事时，你知道，大卫会说，克罗斯会说，伙计，那太蹩脚了，等等。杰森和我就会说，嘿，街头信誉，我们该做什么酷的事？他让我们保持警惕。《发展受阻》是一个很好的节目例子，你知道，我认为那是喜剧的高度，它不道歉也不牵着你的手。我的意思是，你真的必须注意。哦，甚至对我们制作它的人来说，我的意思是，我们不得不不断地要求马修·维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）对他在写的所有这些极其聪明的东西进行喜剧诠释。我的意思是，一切都存在于多个层面上，你需要14层
parenthetical to try to understand. It was very tough for me. I still don't get a lot of it. Yeah, I love that. So if you were asking about David, David and I are a really great marriage of a failure and a lot of success falling short, but we entertain each other. We make each other laugh and we kind of compensate for each other. And the weird thing is in different ways. I mean, he probably is funnier than me, but there are times when I'm bringing the jokes and he's bringing the structure and we just really hand it off back and forth between inspiration and jokes and creativity and structure and sort of focus and grounding the piece. And we just keep balancing that out between ourselves. And it's hard to, um, I don't, I actually don't like thinking about it
括号才能理解。这对我来说非常困难。我到现在还是有很多不明白。是的，我喜欢那个。所以如果你问关于大卫的事，大卫和我是一个失败和很多成功但未达预期的伟大结合，但我们互相娱乐。我们让彼此发笑，我们某种程度上弥补了对方。奇怪的是，以不同的方式。我的意思是，他可能比我更有趣，但有时我带来笑话，他带来结构，我们只是在灵感和笑话、创造力和结构之间来回传递，某种程度上专注于并扎根于作品。我们只是在彼此之间不断平衡这一点。而且很难，嗯，我其实不喜欢想太多
too much, which is a good sign of like something that's kind of magical. You don't want to think about it. It's like, if you're married for a long time, you just go, I just, yeah, I was just going to say that. You can make, you could make the analogy to a good marriage where you identify, well, we don't need two Bob Odenkirks. We got one great one. And so you don't want to marry another Bob. You want to marry somebody who's a proper counterbalance or pleasant opposite to who you are. And you kind of give them, going back to Will's point, her lane and you stay in your lane, you know, David can make certain people laugh and you can make other people laugh and, and that little combo, that cocktail just works so beautifully. And also that you don't need to
，这是一个好迹象，就像某种神奇的东西。你不想去想它。就像，如果你结婚很久了，你只是说，我只是，是的，我正要说那个。你可以做一个类比，就像一段好的婚姻，你确定，好吧，我们不需要两个鲍勃·奥登科克。我们有一个很棒的。所以你不想嫁给另一个鲍勃。你想嫁给一个合适的平衡者或与你相反的人。你某种程度上给他们，回到威尔的观点，她的车道，你留在你的车道，你知道，大卫可以让某些人笑，你可以让其他人笑，那个小组合，那个鸡尾酒效果非常好。而且你也不需要
break it down. You don't need to understand why it works. It just doesn't. You can kind of move on. And, uh, David makes me laugh. Same. I think more than any other person. Uh, I mean, Zach Alfenakis, I think is super funny all the time. Incredible. I think Tim Heidecker is one of the funniest people I know, but David's just like roll just so funny all the time. He likes pranking more than I do. I'm not big into pranking people. He, that's a big part of what David loves. It's a surprise is to do something that sets up the audience or whatever that audience is. I mean, if you're in an elevator with David, he'll start saying something that will disturb the people around you. And that's just, it's a private. And I put the word in quotes,
把它拆解。你不需要理解它为什么有效。它只是不。你可以继续前进。而且，大卫让我发笑。我也是。我认为比任何其他人都多。嗯，我的意思是，扎克·加利凡纳基斯（Zach Galifianakis），我认为他一直超级有趣。不可思议。我认为蒂姆·海德克（Tim Heidecker）是我认识的最有趣的人之一，但大卫就像一直都那么有趣。他比我更喜欢恶作剧。我不喜欢恶作剧。他，那是大卫喜欢的一大部分。这是一个惊喜，就是做一些让观众或无论那个观众是谁感到困惑的事情。我的意思是，如果你和大卫在电梯里，他会开始说一些会打扰周围人的话。而那只是，这是一个私人的。我把这个词加了引号，
joke. Cause how is it funny? They're just, they didn't do anything. They didn't ask for a show. But he loves that stuff. Even in this thing we're talking about right now, he keeps talking about sort of misleads and, and it's like, all right, well, I mean, we'll do a few of them, but he loves that shit. He just wants, well, you got to have David on. I know. We can't make his deal. We just can't make his deal. Believe me. You guys, I, I don't want to say, it was nice of you to want me to do this because you are all more famous than I am. We like to talk to people that we're huge, huge fans of and try to make us a little bit smarter. We, we love you. And we, I've always looked up to you and, and thanks for coming and doing this,
笑话。因为这怎么有趣呢？他们只是，他们什么也没做。他们没要求看表演。但他喜欢那些东西。即使在我们现在谈论的这件事中，他一直在谈论某种误导，就像，好吧，好吧，我的意思是，我们会做几个，但他喜欢那该死的东西。他只是想要，好吧，你得请大卫来。我知道。我们没法达成他的交易。我们就是没法达成他的交易。相信我。伙计们，我，我不想说，你们想让我做这个真是太好了，因为你们都比我出名。我们喜欢和我们非常非常崇拜的人交谈，并试图让我们变得聪明一点。我们，我们爱你。而且我们，我一直很仰慕你，谢谢你来做这个，
man. You're just such a huge talent. And I'm so excited for you that you have so many different chapters and you keep fucking doing whatever you want to do. I think it's, I think it's so rad. Fucking rad. Please direct another movie. Yes. Please, please. That's nice of you. Thanks. Thanks for coming on the show. Thank you, Bob, for doing this. Thanks for having me, guys. We love you. Bye. See you. You too. You know what? I didn't mention to, to Bob, but I wanted to, when I first got my production office for my production company, I'm one of three actors in town with a production company and they, he worked one level below me on the floor below me and he just walked up the stairs one day. He knocked on the door and he goes,
伙计。你真是个巨大的天才。我为你感到非常兴奋，你有这么多不同的篇章，而且你一直在做任何你想做的事情。我认为这，我认为这太棒了。太棒了。请再导演一部电影。是的，请，请。你真是太好了。谢谢。谢谢你来参加节目。谢谢你，鲍勃，做这件事。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。我们爱你。再见。回头见。你也是。你知道吗？我没提到，对鲍勃，但我本来想的，当我第一次拿到我的制作公司的制作办公室时，我是城里三个有制作公司的演员之一，他就在我楼下工作，有一天他走上楼梯。他敲了敲门，他说，
Hey, I'm doing this animated series. Can you come down and do a voice really quick? Oh, I thought he was going to ask you to just keep it down because he's, he's recording up there. And the clogs that you were wearing at work were not working well for him. Right. No. He, he just said, can you come down and do a voice? It'd be so fun. I was like, uh, yeah. I was like, Bob Odenkirk just asked me to do a voice that was so awesome. He was so kind and I just, I don't remember the name of the show. It was like the character's names were in the title of the show, but I don't remember the name of the show, but it was great. It was Will and Grace animated. Do you want us to, yeah, are we supposed to guess? Yeah, guess, go ahead and be a fun game.
嘿，我正在做这个动画系列。你能下来快速配个音吗？哦，我以为他要让你保持安静，因为他，他在上面录音。而且你在工作中穿的木屐对他来说效果不好。对。不。他，他只是说，你能下来配个音吗？那会很有趣。我当时想，呃，是的。我当时想，鲍勃·奥登科克竟然让我配音，那太棒了。他非常友善，我只是，我不记得那个节目的名字了。就像角色的名字在节目的标题里，但我记不起节目的名字了，但它很棒。那是《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）动画版。你想让我们，是的，我们应该猜吗？是的，猜吧，继续，玩个有趣的游戏。
Will, um, how did you, Will, how'd you make Bob Odenkirk's deal on that? So I, I just, um, yeah, I mean, as, as you know, you guys have to do another movie together and things happen in threes. You're, you got two. That's a great idea to remake for others. We should do it, right? We should call Forte. That's so rad. At one point we, we made so little money the opening weekend. Like I think it was like $545,000 opening weekend. It was a complete bust. It was on like eight screens or something, but, uh, and I went to Tom Werner, the producer, and I said, what if we remade it and the budget was what it made opening weekend? And he's like, great, go for it. I'll sign that check today. And, uh, but that was like, you know, 10 years ago,
威尔，嗯，你是怎么，威尔，你是怎么达成鲍勃·奥登科克的交易的？所以，我只是，嗯，是的，我的意思是，正如你们所知，你们必须再一起拍一部电影，事情总是事不过三。你们，你们有两个。那是个重拍其他作品的好主意。我们应该做，对吧？我们应该给福特（Forte）打电话。那太棒了。有一次我们，我们开画周末赚的钱太少了。就像我想是开画周末545,000美元。那完全是个失败。它大概在八个屏幕上放映，但，嗯，我去找了制片人汤姆·沃纳（Tom Werner），我说，如果我们重拍它，预算就是它开画周末赚的钱怎么样？他说，太棒了，去做吧。我今天就签那张支票。而且，嗯，但那大概是，你知道，10年前的事了，
but I, I have thought like it'd be really funny to get that script was so good. It was me and Forte and Kristen Wiig and, uh, shy McBride. And there are lots of people who are haters in it. So many people are in it. It's, and it was a really fun, the script is brilliant. Forte's writing is just brilliant. And the movie's pretty good, but it could have been, as Bob said, we wanted it to be something else. And it, and it wasn't, and it was just one of those things. And he, I think he, uh, was far too self deprecating to say that, you know, that it was all his fault or that any failure of any movie as a director's fault, there's so many other things, not to bore the audience to death, but, you know, the marketing and the date,
但我，我确实想过，如果能得到那个剧本就太有趣了，它太棒了。是我和福特，还有克里斯汀·韦格（Kristen Wiig），还有，嗯，谢伊·麦克布莱德（Shy McBride）。里面有很多讨厌的人。很多人都在里面。它，而且它真的很有趣，剧本很精彩。福特的写作简直太棒了。电影也相当不错，但它本可以，正如鲍勃所说，我们想让它成为别的东西。而它，它不是，它只是那种事情之一。而且，我想他，嗯，太过于自嘲了，不能说，你知道，那是他所有的错，或者任何电影的失败都是导演的错，还有很多其他事情，不是为了让观众感到无聊，但是，你知道，营销和日期，
you know, the studio, the, the, the other films that are out there, you know, is there a storm on the East coast? I mean, it's so many things. You guys did a great job with both those movies. Yeah. I think, and, but, you know, it truly was, it was one of those things where I think a lot of people had, a lot of us involved in it had regret about the way it turned out because the script was so good. And Bob kind of out of the blue coming up to me and, and, uh, sort of making it amends, if you will, almost really was, um, I think it took a lot, you know, showed he was a really, he's a big person and was able to do that with no ego and just kind of go, Hey, for my part, I'm sorry. And I was like, yep, same here. And it was, I thought it was really
你知道，制片厂，那个，那个外面还有其他电影，你知道，东海岸有风暴吗？我的意思是，有太多的事情了。你们两部电影都做得很好。是的。我想，而且，但是，你知道，这确实是，它是那种事情之一，我想很多参与其中的人对它的结果感到后悔，因为剧本太好了。鲍勃出人意料地走过来找我，而且，嗯，某种程度上弥补了，如果你愿意的话，几乎真的是，嗯，我想这花了很多，你知道，表明他是一个非常，他是一个大人物，能够毫无自负地做到这一点，只是说，嘿，就我而言，我很抱歉。而我当时想，是的，我也是。而且我觉得这真的
awesome and a very cool, again, you don't get a lot that obviously in, in, in this business. You know, a lot of people are happy to spread the blame. Yeah. He seems like such a decent guy. He is. He's a really decent guy. So anyway, it was, I'm so excited to have him on and have always been and remain such a huge fan. And then to go from, to start as a writer, you know, he and Conan wrote together and, and with Smigel and, you know, to write on, on SNL, the write on Conan to then writing on the Ben Stiller show, to Mr. Show, to Larry Sanders, direct a bunch and then do Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul and now has this action movie.
太棒了，而且非常酷，再说一次，在这个行业里你显然得不到很多这样的机会。你知道，很多人很高兴把责任推给别人。是的。他看起来是个非常正派的人。他是。他真的是个非常正派的人。所以总之，我很高兴能请他来，而且一直以来都是，并且仍然是一个巨大的粉丝。然后从，从作家开始，你知道，他和柯南（Conan）一起写，而且，和斯迈格尔（Smigel）一起，你知道，在SNL写，在柯南写，然后在本·斯蒂勒秀（Ben Stiller Show）写，到《Mr. Show》，到《拉里·桑德斯秀》（Larry Sanders），导演了一堆，然后做《绝命毒师》和《风骚律师》，现在有了这部动作电影。
It's like, yeah, it's a great career. There's no, there are no limits. You know, we, I joked with you, you know, about, about his lane. I mean, here's a guy who's like, there is, I have no lane. My lane is whatever the fuck I want. I feel like doing in the moment. And for me, that's inspiring. Yeah. Do what, do what takes you in the moment. You know, and even if you want to look for spiders, great. Fill the morning, be late for work. I know. He spent the whole morning looking for spiders and then kind of show up a little bit. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. And then the phone rings. I love just the phone rings and he goes, it's, it's Will and Grace, isn't it? Yeah. Well, you know, if you've been fired before,
这就像，是的，这是一个伟大的职业生涯。没有，没有限制。你知道，我和你开玩笑，你知道，关于，关于他的车道。我的意思是，这是一个像，没有车道的人。我的车道就是我他妈想做的任何事。我觉得那一刻想做什么就做什么。对我来说，这很鼓舞人心。是的。做，做那一刻带给你的事。你知道，即使你想去找蜘蛛，太棒了。填满早晨，上班迟到。我知道。他花了一整个早晨找蜘蛛，然后有点出现。这太搞笑了。这太搞笑了。然后电话响了。我喜欢电话响了，他说，是，是《威尔和格蕾丝》，对吧？是的。好吧，你知道，如果你以前被解雇过，
you know that feeling. I, I've always known when I'm about to get fired and I get a call from Prince Pado and he'd go, well, you were right. They're letting me go, right? Well, it's happened to me a couple of times. Sean, have you been fired? Oh, you don't want to answer that? I'm sorry. Sorry. One more time. What were you saying? Did you just, he's trying to buy out of here. I'll buy. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道那种感觉。我，我一直知道我什么时候要被解雇，我接到普林斯·帕多（Prince Pado）的电话，他会说，好吧，你是对的。他们要让我走，对吧？好吧，这发生在我身上几次了。肖恩，你被解雇过吗？哦，你不想回答那个？我很抱歉。抱歉。再说一次。你在说什么？你刚才，他想买下这里。我会买。聪明。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。